qué importancia tiene la visita de joe
biden a medio oriente
mira la visita del presidente y baile
más que todo es para
busca dar más apoyo a nivel
internacional por la producción de los
del petróleo de los países árabes y ver
la situación en israel mis amigos el
conflicto palestino está en la intención
del presidente iván pero no no se va a
recibir con las mismas mismo entusiasmo
sobre estos temas
la prioridad en israel y en arabia
saudita de los países del golfo ahora es
gran número uno dos y tres es gran iraní
la expansión geopolítica de grant en la
región y en el mundo preocupa mucho
preocupa mucho a los países árabes le
van a pedir al presidente y bailén que
no se dé territorio o terreno para el
acuerdo nuclear con teherán para que no
pueda lograr gran armada tonella y
aparte de irán logrará por ejemplo
concretar la misión de fortalecer los
lazos árabe-israelí
irán es la causa con la cual arabia
saudita más fortalecer su relación con
israel si no es de hecho y están allí a
esta nación no lo lleva aunque llegaban
de estar detrás del escenario pero
públicamente irán en la mano del gran es
la última decisión si muestra eran más
se muestra más agresiva en la región
entonces arabia saudita no tiene otra
otra opción que hacer una alianza o un
acuerdo con israel
restablecer las relaciones diplomáticas
comerciales etcétera porque irán quien y
plan a largo plazo que yo llamo el
triángulo de la instrucción de
interrumpir el comercio internacional y
sea en el estrecho de ormuz que sea del
golfo de adén por el canal de suez y que
sea las bases que ésta
y vas creciendo en el líbano para
hezbollah para interrumpir el tráfico
marítimo y lo más probable vida producto
que está construyendo y será el asia en
rojo ahora como se ve la relación de
eeuu con arabia saudita cuyos líderes
son acusados de cometer violaciones a
los derechos humanos
durante la campaña presidencial el
presidente maya ha puesto como los
derechos humanos de arabia saudita en
primera plana no creo que va a pensar lo
mismo ahora durante su visita o después
de su visita en las relaciones
internacionales hay prioridad entonces
ahora no es la prioridad de eeuu los
derechos humanos en arabia saudita
porque arabia saudita también le va a
decir a eeuu mira hay muchos países más
importantes que tienen abusos de
derechos humanos mucho más de lo que
hacemos nosotros y usted no puede
comparar el derecho humano en arabia
saudita a derechos humanos en eeuu
comparan los de china con para mí al mar
comparado a estos países y después
hablamos de derecho humano en el momento
nuestra oportunidad nuestra prioridad es
como para grande alcanzar un arma
nuclear el tema de las relaciones entre
nosotros no pueden congelar a causa de
su acusación
y por otro lado qué papel juega hoy por
ejemplo eeuu en el conflicto
palestino-israelí por ejemplo qué
diferencias hay entre la administración
de joe biden y la del expresidente de
nostrum mira no hay mucho cambio la
verdad que antes en la previsión árabe
que empujaba a eeuu para avanzar las
negociaciones entre los palestinos y de
israel
por el momento lo mundo árabe ha dejado
esa decisión a los mismos palestinos
amamos ambas el presidente de la
autoridad palestina y podría ser qatar
está jugando al menos un papel de
intermediario entre las facciones
radicales en la franja de gaza con la
autoridad palestina en cisjordania y con
distraer por el momento esto está
funcionando al menos tienen la tienen la
situación bajo control no absoluto no
para siempre pero por el momento no está
manejando qatar